forced to fall back ukrainian troops
have retreated to the edge of sfero
donetsk the city could be key to gaining
control of the eastern industrial
heartland
authorities say despite the retreat
troops are not about to concede the city
of lizachansk is also wedged between
russian forces in luhansk moscow says it
now controls over 90 percent of the
province it's one of two provinces that
make up ukraine's embattled dombass
region ukrainian president florida
messalensky stresses the importance of
the fight for feral donetsk
it is a very dreadful and difficult
fighting
perhaps it's one of the most difficult
battles during this war
i am thankful to each and everyone who
is defending this region to a great
extent the fate of our donbass is being
decided there now
our correspondent young philipp schultz
is standing by in kiev the capital
sverro donetsk as we've heard there and
time and again is key for control of
this region what would it mean for
ukraine
if it lost control
yes severe donetsk has become a highly
symbolic battleground just like places
like bucha and mario pole in the weeks
before as you know
russia has kept
lowering his
its its goals in
in in ukraine at least for the moment
first it wanted to take over the capital
then it wanted to focus on the east and
the south now it's focusing on the
donbass region so it's throwing in
almost all its force uh in the area
around severo donetsk at the moment and
it's under high pressure to present
results there uh if they manage to take
over the area they will probably very
quickly try to
install russian structures there but of
course ukraine
will
certainly not let that happen and will
probably conduct counter offensives so
we will probably still see
long and heavy fighting in the region
despite the war dragging on and so many
uncertainties why are so many ukrainians
returning home now to other parts of the
country
i think there are many reasons for this
just
as we discussed before the battle has
shifted mainly to the east of the
country so in other regions of the
country there is
almost some feeling of normality despite
all the air raids that
continue also a lot of
families were separated
you
mainly the the women the mothers and the
the children could go abroad the uh
others stayed behind and a lot of people
here have the feeling that this war
could drag on for months if not for
years
let's have a look at the reports what's
people from the town of bucha have told
me
boris offers people in his town of bucha
in espresso and with it a little bit of
normality
this is what his cafe looked like when
he came back a few weeks ago he said the
russian stole everything even his sink
nearly everything is working again now
he's just missing a few windows
i crossed like broken bridge to go to
zakir to to get coffee to get milk to
get like
some cookies after first guest come over
here
and they said like oh my gosh you're the
best you open we need it i miss the
coffee
next door the block of flats is still
standing but is badly damaged hit by
several rockets or mortars some people
are returning here too keen to try to
reunite their families and rebuild their
lives elvira is one of them she fled
just after the war started taking her
two small children to safety in poland
she got back home just a few days ago
many people warned me saying we should
stay abroad for longer but it was my
decision
i just realized that this conflict this
war could drag on for years
sooner or later i had to come home
she and her husband nicola were lucky
they only lost a window upstairs the
people lost pretty much everything
destroyed by a rocket elvira knows the
rockets could also come back and
sometimes questions her decision to
bring her children home
it's frightening
when you hear about new bombings you
immediately think where could i run to
how do i save the children
my bags are still packed i haven't even
unpacked them
boris knows his wife and child are safe
they are still in switzerland one
element of certainty when everything
still feels up in the air
i don't know what i'm going to expect
tomorrow because like yeah yesterday we
got
shooted
in the gear got bombed and killed i
don't know i'm not planning nothing i'm
just leaving by one day right now
and yet as he mixes cocktails again he
is making plans he wants to offer other
returnees drinks and seating outside on
the terrace this summer
thanks for reporting on philip just one
more question how difficult is it to
piece together your life
among such destruction
extremely difficult of course there's
the very concrete fear that there could
still be mines or under other unexploded
devices in the area so you definitely
don't want your children go out and play
there then there are the psychological
scars the trauma especially of the
people who stayed behind and had to
witness all the horror
last but not least a lot of people have
financial problems and there's this
uncertainty
that the war could return to their
region so nobody really wants to invest
money or make
a big plans so there is some feeling of
a return to normality but if you have a
closer look it's
often a quite superficial feeling
and philip thank you very much for the
analysis
well the war in ukraine is well into its
fourth month with no sign of ending can
russia keep up its offensive war is
expensive beyond the death and
destruction the costs of mounting a
military campaign are massive
tanks missiles fuel not to mention
feeding an army it's believed russia is
spending 900 million euros a day in
ukraine
just think about it russian forces have
fired thousands of missiles many
estimated at over a million euros each
then there's the loss of military
hardware analysts say ukrainian forces
have destroyed hundreds of russian tanks
they're also said to cost at least a
million euros each but much more
expensive ukraine's sinking of the
moskva warship in the black sea is
estimated to have cost moscow over 700
million euros
even with such staggering costs surging
oil prices are handing russia the
revenue to pay for the war
analysts say the kremlin's ability to
sell oil and gas will allow it to
finance the fighting for some time
well let's bring in frank ledwidge a
british military officer and an analyst
on our regular analyst on our show frank
uh tell us about this 900 million euro
figure first of all uh just how
long can russia based on that
afford to continue this war
well then at the outset of the war
russia had a war chest they'd
saved as it were about 600 billion
dollars now they'll be coming to the end
of that quite soon
and of course as you will be aware
there is some fear of default in the
russian economy that's not just because
of the capital outlays of the war
of five to nine million a day and that's
really a minimum
someone almost put it even higher than
that
so that's russia
ukraine spends something in the region
in capital outlay alone
of they say 10 billion
dollars a month
this is a hugely expensive
war and that's before we get to
reconstruction or indeed the longer term
costs which will be much much greater
can you explain the difference in costs
between the two countries
yes for ukraine we've got
costs
accrued so far of between two and three
hundred billion dollars in
infrastructure damage infrastructure
damage to russia so far as nougat tree a
couple of oil refineries and some
experimental centers i think
this will be epochal for the ukrainians
but those aren't the only costs of war
is you yourself said not one minute ago
there are the personnel costs
and of course to ukraine the ongoing
difficulties with respect to trade
they're not being able to get most of
their harvest out
and similarly for russia sanctions will
soon begin to bite although sadly they
probably haven't so far and europe is
still paying for their oil
so those costs to ukraine are especially
crippling and decadally so
what about the costs to other countries
allies say of ukraine who were uh
spending up big on on sending over
hardware and also um
aid in many cases
yes well you say ben spending big and it
does sound that the numbers sound big
the uk says it spent about 1.3 billion
which is roughly
three percent of what we spent on our
disastrous war in afghanistan uh the
americans have so far committed about 40
billion dollars which is one percent of
what they committed to their wasteful
and totally pointless war in iraq in
which i fought
these are large sums or so it would
appear initially but these sums now are
not being wasted and part of that 40
billion of course from the americans is
going to help the ukrainians sustain
their economy as well
so those costs will continue as for
european countries we're talking the low
hundreds of millions of euros uh drops
in the ocean in their budgets
of course a lot of this money is also
providing jobs uh supporting other
economies around the world but um
what about these countries boosting
their defense spending right now is that
something that's going to be here to
stay
well one thing so germany for example as
you know committed a hundred billion uh
euros to its defense that won't do much
to make germany a real power what it
will do is repair decades of failure to
invest all presidents over the last u.s
presidents over the last 20 years have
complained rightly to europe that they
aren't spending enough now what's
happening is european countries are
starting to recapitalize their military
not really increase them recapitalize
them and that's going to cost something
perhaps if that money had been spent
earlier the deterrent effect of that to
russia may have uh
may have bitten but uh that's that's all
what might have been but uh these again
are small figures compared with the
potential cost to europe of this war
with ukraine failing in this war which
is a failed state in europe landlocked
with a large army and an angry
population and we cannot afford that for
european security which is why this
money is not being wasted it's been well
spent unlike what we spent in the middle
east
thanks for breaking down the numbers for
us frank language from the university of
portsmouth in england
thank you ben
you